Okay, so now we have registered an app engine
project and we are almost ready to do some
coding. But just before we do that, let's talk
about supporting different devices for a while. One big challenge
when designing service-side applications today is that there are
so many different devices from so many different vendors
that you need to support. Different browsers, smartphone, tablet's
and computer. All having different API's that should be used.
Initially, we will be using the browser for our course project. But later we
will be able to support a mobile phone without rewriting a single line of code.
Having to consider this when you design your
server-side application is a lot of work. So how
can we solve this problem? Well, the Google Cloud
platform has solved this problem for you with a
product called Cloud Endpoints. When you use Cloud Endpoints
you can create one single API for your server
application called a Cloud Endpoint API. Cloud Endpoints can
then generate a client side API for many different
devices from many different vendors. This is great of
course because it allows you to focus on just
server side application and Cloud Endpoints will make sure
that it supports many different devices. You will learn a
lot more about Cloud Endpoints since we will use
it when we build out the course project. Enough
said, we have now created an app engine project
using the developer's console and looked at the benefits of
Cloud Endpoints. It's time for you to
get a development environment up and running.